[Music]
first of all can we talk about something
for a second Google is the worst company
on Earth at keeping things a secret and
I don't think it's on purpose like some
people think it's an intentional leak
and oh they're they're letting stuff get
out about their phone so that's free
press no I think they're just bad at it
like really really bad at it so
everything about the phone is already
out before it even comes out
that's just the way it is with pixel
phones now pixel anything
anyway this is the pixel 7A you've
probably heard about it or seen some
things uh and it turns out pretty much
everything you've seen is true because
it's a pixel but really what you should
know is this is the new mid-ranger from
Google and it's a bit more expensive
than the previous one 7A costs 499 and
it's very similar to the pixel 7. let's
talk about it so first things first yes
the price did go up the pixel 6A was 449
that release this is the 7A so there
should be a good reason to add 50 more
dollars so let's just start with what's
new which is wireless charging and a new
90 Hertz display honestly these are
welcome features wireless charging is a
nice one for convenience I will say it's
definitely not fast wireless charging
it's only seven and a half Watts here so
I've noticed literally when I'm
navigating and this is wireless charging
in my car and it's got high brightness
GPS stuff going it just holds its charge
it doesn't lower or go up it just stays
the same but hey if you have a wireless
charger sitting around at the desk at
work or at the bedside or something like
that it'll definitely be good for a
trickle charge overnight which not every
phone in this price range can say they
have so that's good and then the 90
Hertz display is a funny one because
it's actually off by default on this
phone like when you first take it out
the box and start using it it's a 60
hertz phone but you can go into the
display settings and turn turn on smooth
display suddenly it's 50 percent more
frames and it's dramatically smoother
about as smooth as the pixel 7 was it's
also the same tensor G2 chip and the
same 8 gigs of RAM so performance feels
pretty similar to the pixel 7 at 90
Hertz it makes a big difference I do not
enjoy using this phone at 60 hertz for
this price it did seem a little bit
choppier like it was dropping frames and
actually operating at 45 to 55 Hertz so
yeah turn on that 90 Hertz build quality
wise that is where you'll see at least
on paper it does take the small step
down from the pixel 7. uh
plastic back and the the rails are still
metal which is nice and it is also IP67
instead of ip68 but honestly you'd be
hard-pressed to notice just like using
this phone holding it there's no
creaking no bending no nothing screams
low quality about this build at all so I
think that was well done and this is a
slightly smaller 6.1 inch flat display
still 1080P and it's up to 90 Hertz like
I said and it does have some serious
color shifting and banding when you get
off axis but honestly you know it's
still bright it still looks good enough
for this price it's Gorilla Glass 3 and
also even though the display is slightly
smaller the slightly thicker bezels just
bring it right back up to basically the
same size of a phone as the pixel 7. so
it feels like another fair trade and
then there is a new set of colors this
This little light blue is called c as in
Ocean it's the C but there's also a
charcoal and snow which are the black
and white ones and there's also a red
like coral colored one that one is an
online only Google Store color pretty
fire actually but you know Channel
sponsored dbrand will let you spice it
up I've never actually shouted out the
Jerry rig everything tear down skin
because usually dbrand has to wait for
someone to actually do the tear down
luckily though they were able to pull
some strings and get this one made ahead
of time so it's ready right for launch
and this is a rare first look at the
inside of the phone on camera through
this skin and it's it's 15 off too along
with everything else on their site right
now for you guys as long as you go to
dbrand.com MKBHD and use code everything
but bottom line it still very much looks
like a pixel the metal wraparound visor
the pill cut out for the cameras the
antenna bands in the right places the
slot speakers the buttons are still very
clicky I mean if this is they've done
the hardware well this is a very good
trade-off for the hardware price and
then do I really even need to get into
the software because this story kind of
writes itself they do all the same
software stuff in the a series phones as
they do on the more premium pixels which
I like not everybody does that so all
the same features all the same stuff
that I like about every other pixel is
also here I've called the pixel the
smartest smartphone in the world because
of how good Google assistant is how good
the voice to text is with all the
on-device transcription the incredible
voice recorder app the Google Assistant
stuff that screens calls and waits on
hold for me the now playing feature that
hears songs in the background wherever
you go and identifies them for you the
material you stuff throughout everything
that identifies your wallpaper and
matches your system colors to it and of
course the promised three years of
software updates which hilariously isn't
the longest promise support in the
industry anymore that actually goes to
Samsung's phones which promise like four
to five years of support but
nevertheless no surprises here so really
my only two question marks when I got
this phone were battery and cameras so
battery would be kind of interesting
because it's roughly the same size
battery as the pixel 7 so would it have
the same battery life or not but then
also cameras because For the first time
in a while there's new cameras in here
all new cameras that we've never seen in
a pixel before so a departure from the
tried and true so first for battery 4
385 milliamp hours 18 watt charging kind
of slow and seven and a half watt
wireless charging even slower and then
total battery life I'm gonna say average
at best so it's a full day of use but
definitely nothing more even at 90 Hertz
which is fine you know it's mid-range so
I got quite a few days with the the
three to four hours of screen on time at
90 Hertz with my typical usage and I'd
have like 10 left at the end of the day
so I'm not really worried about it dying
before the end of the day unless it's
crazy heavy but even then the wireless
charging can kind of save you if you
want to prolong its death a little bit
we'll see how this ages over time but
for now I'm giving it a c plus battery
life if that makes sense but let's talk
about these cameras okay so pixel 6A
last year played it super safe with the
cameras because it used the same 12
megapixel sensor from the previous like
four years of pixels in a row that
Infamous IMX 363 sensor that did so well
this one has a brand new 64 megapixel
main camera paired with a 13 megapixel
Ultra wide and a 13 megapixel selfie
camera so when I first started testing
it I mean I'm thinking all right well
this new sensor keep up with the old
tried and true pixel 6A because we all
know how good those old cameras were but
pretty quickly it became clear that
Google has done the work to tighten up
the processing with the new sensor and
actually sort of match it this time and
take advantage of the actual larger
sensor so it's not just about the
megapixel count matter of fact this 64
megapixel sensor bins down to 16
megapixels by default every time and
there is no way in Google's app to take
full 64 megapixel photos but it's more
about the larger size of the sensor
which can bring in more light and give a
more shallow natural depth of field so
yeah pixel photos look pretty good for a
500 phone there are tons of dynamic
range without being too hdre and
actually kind of feels like they've
evened it out a little bit so it's a
little less contrasty but it still has
that famous contrasty pixel look and
then that F 1.9 Max aperture combined
with the new sensor means you can take
close-ups of things and have a really
shallow depth of field and you can take
better low-light photos with faster
shutter speeds at night with night sight
there is no macro mode I noticed but you
can get pretty close up probably I'm
gonna say like five inches away from the
subject and still be fine not too much
fringing
the ultra wide here has a lot of the
same characteristics but it's
particularly distorted and warped at the
corners I feel like this this is
something like I would expect Google to
improve more with their software maybe
they'll update this over time but for
now the Distortion look is pretty
noticeable but it is wide and then the
Selfies they look like pixel selfies
honestly very solid no complaints tons
of range that's a good selfie camera for
video you can do 4K 60 from the main
camera which the Samsung a54 I just
tested I don't think could even do that
but then it's 4K 30 from the other
cameras which is fine looks normal
it this is a top three mid-range
smartphone camera but hold on to that
thought all the rest of the little parts
of this phone I've tested were right in
line for this price the haptics were
pretty good not as good as the more
expensive pixels but pretty good the
optical fingerprint reader is just a
beat slower than the super fast
ultrasonic ones but none of the pixels
have particularly fast fingerprint
readers anyway so this is par for the
course and when the sun hit it I could
also see that it was slightly angled to
the right not sure if that's normal or
not I just know I haven't seen it like
that before but let's be real here for
the a series it all comes down to the
price point and this one has gone up so
it is still mid-range but it's like
upper like premium mid-range at 500
bucks Verizon is also going to sell a
millimeter wave version and theirs will
be 550 bucks classic Verizon but still
premium mid-range right this is a good
phone and I think a lot of people will
get it and really like it but for the
price I would actually rather go for the
pixel 7. it is six months older yes than
this brand new a series phone but it's
gonna have the same specs it's the same
tensor chip and same RAM and everything
but it will have more capable cameras on
the back and the front a faster 20 watt
wireless charging and then a bunch of
the smaller little things better haptics
better speakers and a cheaper phone it's
actually glass on the back like there's
just a bunch of little things that add
up to a better experience overall it's
thinner bezels better accessories
because it's six months old already it's
also ip68 instead of IP67 and this phone
is like 5.99 standard and it was when it
came out but it's regularly on sale for
much less than that if you can get this
phone pixel 7 for in the 500 to 550
range I would take this over the 7A but
I guess that's just the middle child
effect because Google is now trying this
sort of newer thing where they're
offering more things at once more pixels
for different prices they're keeping the
6A in the lineup at 349 which I think is
a really good deal and so now you can
get a pixel anywhere from 350 bucks to
1800 bucks
choice is yours 7A is kind of right in
the middle let me know what you think
about this phone and whether or not
you'd get this or the older seven in the
meantime thanks for watching check out
all the new stuff on the channel if you
haven't already and I'll catch you guys
in the next one peace